on parlait de pascal obispo séounes et
nous rejoindre une machine à cuba on se
posait la question est il de nouveau
goldman alors que son nouvel album sort
là c'est dans l'est dans les prochains
jours où il est déjà sorti j'ai sorti
par dont il est sorti jean bêtise
donc voilà ce que ces nouveaux goldman
ou pas myriam palombes à vous qui le
connaissent aussi par la presse people
voilà ce que c'est le nouveau jean
jacques goldman du tout pour moi ce
n'est pas du tout le genre jacques
goldman de demain d'un côté on a 30
millions de 10 de l'autre 4 millions en
plus on a une personnalité complètement
différente de celle de jean jacques
goldman avec un ego assez important
c'est pas un reproche mais voilà et du
coup pour tenir les [ __ ] il faut
quand même être dans l'ombre ce qui ne
sera pas le cas de pascal obispo
d'accord il ya deux minutes en fait
c'est dire non mais le vrai c'est que je
pense à leur magasin team honda il faut
dire oui aussi magali alors moi je
trouve que pour tenir les [ __ ] faut
surtout être généreux et je trouve que
pascal obispo c'est quelqu'un de
généreux qui a un grand talent cas pas
le même âge que goldman donc
effectivement faut lui laisser le temps
aussi d'arriver à ce niveau là
maintenant il a fait des choses
extraordinaires et pour une petite
anecdote
moi quand j'ai démarré mon activité dans
ce monde là venant du sud connaissant
personne
j'ai voulu aller au-delà aussi faire
autre chose que la téléralité donc j'ai
contacté des artistes dont pascal obispo
qu'a pris le temps de répondre à une
nana du sud qui connaît personne
il m'a téléphoné j'ai envoyé un message
il m'a répondu il m'a appelé j'ai
discuté avec lui pendant au moins 10
minutes uniquement pour donner des
conseils pour être agréable et gentil
parce qu'il n'a pas d'un style ça c'est
un beau témoignage publie aussi un le
sidaction desquesnes cause il est là à
myriam vous pensez un peu court c'est un
gentil mec hyper sensible vous répondez
non pourtant et c'est un petit aparté sa
gentil mec mais très sensible qui a
beaucoup d'ego en effet je sais pas s'il
a commis comme valeur sûre qu'il est
qu'il puisse faire abstraction sa
personnalité pour prendre la main sur
les [ __ ]
non moi c'est un type assez gentil
néanmoins aussi il a été un peu sévère
sur le nombre d'albums
il a fait beaucoup de tubes pour tout le
monde et où la seule chose parle pour un
goal mangold a gardé beaucoup de gros
tubes pour luis obispo n'a pas fait
autant de tubes pour lui que goldman il
est moins bon au niveau phrase i
phraséologie fragile moins bon au niveau
linguistique que justement est-ce qu'il
ya pas aussi ce petit côté un peu quand
les gens sont sans voix elle m'a dit
évidemment avec nous mais quand les gens
te retire un peu de la lumière
tout d'un coup ils ont toutes les
qualités en lice et canyon est sorti
généraux alors qm me leader tout ça
c'est seconde émane celle qu'on disait
la même chose de lui de goldman quand il
avait 50 ans les autres et ça c'est la
nostalgie c'est comme les gens qui ont
pu être odieux de leur vivant et quand
ils sont morts oui c'est quand même un
mec bien
on dira que chamakh bien vous pensez je
dirai la vérité gérez vous étiez un
[ __ ] moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec l'intitulé est il le
nouveau goldman parce que le but ce
n'est pas de faire du copier coller la
copie est toujours moins bien que
l'original en revanche être peut-il être
le nouveau leader oui comme par exemple
patrick bruel parce que c'est c'est pour
choisir pour vous c'est qu'ils ou elles
obispo est très bien et justement il
semble qu'il a beaucoup d'ego mais il
est aussi généreux parce qu'il a fait
énormément de tubes phares d'autres
personnes et a laissé une grande
reconnaissance publique il souffre d'un
défaut dans tous les sens du métier
peut-être que ça elle valoriserait
paraître il serait contraint moluques et
ensuite la conclusion de daniel les
français l'attendent
est ce que parce que pascal obispo a
toujours eu un caractère tempétueux il a
beaucoup râlé l'a beaucoup dit des
victoires de la musique même pas le
public me reconnais pas les critiques
ceci quand je me déguise en faire un
captain samourai s'appelait pas faim il
a quand même beaucoup râlé il a un peu
ça augmente à ce niveau-là et coleman y
avait ce côté que tout le monde aimait
un peu rassembleur que la façon de
gagner la confusion ne remplace les
attentes de taux par daniel quand tu
écoutes jade duell ma chérie comme la
concussion dernière
[Musique]
alors daniel la télévision minutes sur
les applaudit ni sur le jingle batum
place j'avais quelqu'un vraiment mais
qui d'autre pour remplacer jean jacques
goldman même si évidemment ça sera
jamais nouveau jour la gauche pour moi
pascal obispo c'est le fils naturel de
jean jacques goldman et de line renaud
c'est à dire les cadeaux qu'il a le
talent artistique de jean jacques
goldman et qu'il a deux énormément sur
le sida avec line renaud la raison
d'être c'est quand même une limite donc
il faut pas oublier ça donc voilà pour
moi alors tout le sait bien c'est par là
s'est arrêtée là je suis d'accord avec
toi je vous rappelle que jeu complet pas
souvent ça va être